what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story in
this chapter we have huge developments
with the Luffy and kaido fight including
crazy new powers and big signs that it's
almost over but we also get to see how
other fan favorite characters are doing
as well so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing these one
piece reviews I want to keep them coming
you know what to do Channel parking with
it and smash that like button remember
smashing is pirate king energy and
passing a scared Orochi energy so Choose
Wisely if you haven't make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you won't miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos and all the yonko Warlords most
recently a much requested update video
on all 11 mythical Zone users and much
more link to that is in the description
and now without further Ado let's jump
into its spoilers and all this chapter
is called rhizo and at first that wasn't
the most hyped chapter title for me but
after we're done with the chapter I
think we'll all agree that he deserved
the honor we pick up where we left off
with Luffy having just punched through
kaido's face in the last chapter his
face was intact because of some cartoon
logic but it had to hurt as kaido is on
the ground Luffy is rubberizing the
ground beneath him turning it into a
trampoline and jumping up and down for
fun while contemplating what he should
call the last move knows something
pretty hilarious to see him coming up
with a name for a move midianko fight
kaido as we probably expected is more or
less alright yes there's panting but he
gets up asking who are you to Luffy
kaido knows he's called Straw Hat Luffy
but I think these lines are more and
more signaling to us that kaido is
putting the pieces together and finding
out that Luffy is the New Joy boy even
if Luffy doesn't know it yet as if to
confirm this we see zunisha thinking how
nostalgic it is to hear the Rhythm Of
Joy Boy again then he speaks as if he
were speaking to his old Joy boy friend
and says it's as if you're right there
how exhilarating this all feels like
fate I can't help but think that we
should put our faith into this boy end
quote so these words are interesting
because it does distinguish between the
old Joy boy and Luffy he may be the
quote unquote New Joy boy but he's not
the old Joy boy in other words Luffy is
Luffy and won't be taken over by some
old version of Joy boy still zunisha
feels like putting his faith into Luffy
back to Luffy who answers kaido who me a
Monkey D Luffy the man who's gonna
surpass you and become the king of the
Pirates I know Luffy always says this
but it hits different every time
depending on the circumstances and while
it may have been harder to believe last
time he said it now I think most of us
are pretty certain he'll get the job
done with his new Godly form I love this
man's persistence and unflinching result
kaido is glad to see Luffy still has
that big mouth by which I assume he
means his smile kaido is smiling too
saying we call this an Awakening your
mind and body are finally able to
harness the potential of your ability
and what a ridiculous power it is end
quote this implies that kaido has
already awakened which makes sense and
as I said before I hope this Awakening
based on his fruit was the
transformation from a Magikarp to a
Gyarados and if that line confuses you
it will make a lot more sense if you
watched a brand new 11 mythical zones
and their powers explained video link in
the description kaido goes on to say
he's lost his main Castle everything
he's built in this war but he supposes
the same is true for Luffy not really
though since all Luffy's Fighters will
be fine eventually and most of them even
as we speak are still in solid shape but
Luffy says I'm not through yet he'll
take back everything kaido has stolen no
matter what which is such a funny thing
to hear from one pirate to another but
Luffy has a strong moral compass and he
is not okay with stealing from the
innocent and needy kaido is still going
dropping at gundari meteor shower and
hits Luffy over and over again still so
funny to see Luffy's face wrap around
the spiked weapon Luffy then punches
back and ow the fists move through
kaido's body and looks so unnatural and
painful gotta hand it to these mythical
zones their endurance is off the charts
one might even say it's ridiculous Luffy
starts coughing and we're like what's
going on is he gonna transform back but
it's actually the fumes from the castle
kind of realize that if the fumes are
already here on the roof that means
thousands of Luffy's men are trapped
below kaido says they'll roast to death
this may be him trying to get Luffy to
leave since the panting kaido is in bad
condition or it may be him trying to get
to Luffy mentally but I love to see
Luffy confident and unfazed as usual he
says he left everything that's happening
down there to them and he's got nothing
to worry about other than sending kaido
flying I love to see his trust in his
crew it practically gives me goosebumps
not only is the crew trusting the
captain the captain is also fully
trusting The Crew kaido looking pretty
beat up uses his Scabbard cutter wind
slice attack and Luffy Dodges it by
pulling his upper body up so that the
attack moves between his very extended
legs love this scene and as a little
bonus we see the attack slice through a
boulder in the back like it's nothing
showing how dangerous the attack is we
then briefly jump to the others Nami and
Chopra are together and dealing with the
fire Zeus can't help since the flame is
so big his Reign would just be eaten up
lost polar bear friend Beppo has to be
carried since he's obviously not good
with heat that's actually a hilarious
detail about Beppo that makes a lot of
sense there's been a lot of talk on how
Law's crew isn't that reliable and them
begging for their Captain to save them
here doesn't really help their case we
get more comedy with people thinking
that Brook suffered a lot and is now a
burnt up corpse thanks to what happened
here and he has to explain that that's
not the case Robin suggests that there
may not be a way outside died Sanji is
helping ladies which makes sense good on
you Sanji Apu is arguing with a number
not the most exciting scene Usopp is
doing his best to save kinemon Kiku and
himself while giraffe Hamlet assists
Frankie is carrying Zorro and looking
for Chopper to help or Zorro isn't going
to make it he worries I also love
hearing the line keep whining like a
bunch of weaklings and I'll burn you
myself that's some boss energy right
there Then Jim Bane rides will team up
to save the day they trust each other
because Luffy trusts them both ryzo
promised he'd never be unprepared like
the day Odin's Castle burned he promised
to never let himself be helpless again
and so at Zoe he took the insane amount
of water zunisha used to wash itself and
captured it and now he releases it with
ninja scroll Jutsu elephant bath an
insane amount of water is released that
jimbei helps direct accurately so it
puts out the fire of the castle I
absolutely love this and it may seem
random but it totally makes sense that
Rizal decided to be ready for this since
yes he already almost let Momo and the
others burn in a castle once so he
wanted to ensure it didn't happen again
epic stuff I didn't love the rhizo
versus fukuro kudru fight I mean I liked
it but I didn't love it but this I love
Rizal has more than earned my respect
side note we see killer being saved by
the water as well then we see Yamato and
Momo talking Yamato says something very
interesting namely that kaido won't be
able to sustain his flame clouds much
longer she says he's at his limits and
you think she'd be the one to know this
is huge news and it was hinted at with
all of the panting that kaido is doing
but this seemingly confirms it Momo is
worried but Yamato insists that their
only option is for Momo to create Cloud
strong enough to hold onigashima and
that that was always their only option
lastly we see lightning god Luffy AKA
Luffy in the sky holding a freaking
lightning bolt like the Greek God Zeus
himself not the one piece Cloud but the
Greek god this was one of my questions
when we saw the new form since it
seemingly suggests he could do anything
could he generate anything could he
generate lightning from nothing for
instance in this case we can't assume
that for sure since it is stormy but
either way at the very least Luffy can
grab hold of lightning and use it as a
weapon which is just insane this is why
I say mythical zones are better than
logias because now Luffy can use
lightning powers and that's just one
facet of his powers which include way
way more things the panel really makes
him look like a god coming down to the
grounded kaido we're told onigashima is
about to fall both Fighters are smiling
and we're told by the narrator that
Luffy and his men are taking the future
into their own hands
wow what a chapter honestly I love
constantly seeing Luffy's new moves in
this form and the lightning sword thing
is epic can't wait to see the next
chapter although there will be a break
MVP this chapter goes to rhizo our boy
did great obviously Luffy is gonna get
the vast majority of these chapters just
because of his new form and awesomeness
but this one has to go to rhizo but that
is it for this one let me know your
thoughts on the chapter and what you're
expecting to happen next if you did
enjoy it you know what to do channel the
Power King within and smash that like
button with no mercy remember smashing
his pirate king energy and passing is
scared Orochi energy so Choose Wisely if
you haven't make this video subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications or you will miss
future one piece videos and updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos and all the yonko Warlords most
recently a much requested update video
on all 11 mythical Zone users and much
more link to that is in the description
and until next time see ya Space Cowboys